[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK, so
let's finish the proof
that we started at the end
of the lecture last time.
I usually don't end lectures
in the middle of a proof.
But since this lecture
and the lecture
before will come to
you at the same time,
I didn't feel so bad about it.
All right, so we were
trying to prove this theorem
that if there's a rational
number so that it's
equal to the
supremum of the set,
then x is bigger than or equal
to 1 and its square gives me 2.
And so far, what we've
shown is that if I
have an element, a
rational number that
is given by the supremum, then
it's bigger than or equal to 1
and x squared has to be
bigger than or equal to 2.
And so now, we would like to
show that, in fact, x squared
equals 2.
Now, since x squared is
bigger than or equal to 2,
it's either equal to
2 or bigger than 2.
And we want to show that the
second possibility is not
possible.
So we're going to prove that
the second possibility is not
possible by contradiction.
So let's assume that the thing
that we say cannot happen does
happen and we're going to
derive a false statement.
So define h.
This is going to be x
squared minus 2 over 2x
And so note a couple of
things that since x squared
is bigger than 2, this implies h
is bigger than 0, which implies
x minus h is less than x.
So what is the
contradiction going to be?
It's going to be that
this element x minus h is,
in fact, an upper
bound for the set E.
And this will contradict the
fact that x is the supremum.
In other words, it's
the least upper bound
for the set E. There's
no upper bound for E that
can be less than x.
All right, so we now
prove that x minus h
is an upper bound
for this set E. Now,
let's take a look at
x minus h squared.
Then this is equal to x squared
minus 2xh plus h squared.
Now, just given
by if we just plug
in what h is, this
is equal to x squared
minus x squared minus 2.
So that's putting h in.
And then the 2x here
cancels with the 2x there.
So I just get x squared
minus 2 plus h squared, which
equals 2 plus h squared.
Now remember, h is
a positive number.
So 2 plus a positive number,
this is bigger than 2.
So x minus h squared
is bigger than 2.
So now, I want to show--
I'm going to use this
to show that x minus h
is an upper bound for E So
let q be in E. q squared
is less than 2.
Then I have q squared is less
than 2, which is less than x
minus h squared by what
we just proved here.
So let me write this
out or just summarize
that what we proved here
was x minus h squared
is bigger than 2.
So we have q squared is
less than 2 is less than x
minus h squared.
So that means 0 is bigger
than x minus h squared minus q
squared.
q squared is less than this
so than if I just subtract it
I get this inequality.
So that implies that
0 is bigger than--
now, this is the
difference of two squares.
So I can write this as x
minus h plus q minus q.
Now, if I just write
out what x minus h
is using the
definition of h, this
is equal to x squared plus
2 over 2x plus q over x
minus h minus q.
Now, the product of these
two numbers is positive.
This number is positive
because q is positive.
And so that means
their sum is positive.
So I have something
positive times this.
So I can divide by this positive
thing and keep the inequality.
So that implies that
0 is less than x
minus h minus q, which implies
that q is less than x minus h.
All right, so we started
off with an element of E,
an arbitrary element of E. And
we proved that q is less than x
minus h.
Thus, for all q in
E, q is less than x
minus h, which
implies that x minus h
is an upper bound for E. So
let me keep that board for now
while I write the last
sentence or so of this proof.
So we stated that x minus h
is an upper bound for E, which
implies since x is
the supremum of E,
it should be less than or equal
to all upper bounds, which
implies h is less
than or equal to 0.
But this is a
direct contradiction
to h being a positive number.
So this is the false
statement we ultimately prove.
But the idea is that if x
squared is bigger than 2,
you can find a lower bound--
I mean an upper bound,
which is strictly
smaller than x, which
contradicts the fact that x
is the greatest
lower bound for E.
But remember, what was our
original assumption to begin
with in this line of reasoning?
That was that x squared
is bigger than 2.
And that concludes the proof.
All right, so this was
a statement about just
if I have some element
that's a rational number
and it's equal to the supremum,
then it's square has to be 2.
Now, I'm going to prove that
basically no such element
exists, and therefore that
the rational numbers do not
have the least upper
bound property, which
was the discussion
above those two
lines in that circle
on that board up there.
So what's the theorem
we're going to prove?
The set E as before.
So this is a rational number
such that q is bigger than 0.
q squared is less than 2.
It is bounded above and
has no supremum in Q. So
I'm not just saying that--
so this set E sits
inside my ordered set,
which is my universe Q. I'm
not saying that it doesn't have
a supremum in E. I'm
saying it doesn't
have a supremum in the
universe where it sits.
And therefore, the
rational numbers
do not have the least
upper bound property
because this set is a set
which is bounded above
and has no supremum in q.
So the first thing
I want to show
is that this set E
is bounded above.
Let q be in E. Then q
squared is less than 2,
which is less than 4.
So this tells me
4 minus q squared
is positive, which
tells me 2 minus
q times 2 plus q is positive.
Now, since 2 is positive
and q is positive,
2 plus q is positive.
So I can divide both
sides of this inequality
by this, 2 plus q,
without changing
the inequality, which implies--
I'm just going to
flip this inequality.
Thus, for all q in
E, q is less than 2.
So 2 is an upper
bound for the set E.
OK, so that proves that
the set E is bounded above.
So now, I'm going to prove
that no supremum mom exists
by using the previous
theorem, which
says if I have a supremum,
then its square must be 2.
OK, so now, we show that
the sup of E does not exist.
And we do this by contradiction.
Now, I know it seems like a
lot of the proofs we're doing
are by contradiction.
This should not give
you the impression
that all proofs should
be done by contradiction.
Many proofs that you
will do in the homework
can be done directly,
meaning not by contradiction.
For example, this
first little proof
that E is bounded above, this
is a direct proof, meaning I
prove directly that
it's bounded above.
I do not assume that
it's not bounded above
and arrive at a contradiction.
But proof by contradiction
is very tempting
because it at least gets
you going somewhere.
If you can assume
not, then you get
to a next step, which
this assumption implies
something else.
And hopefully, you can
keep going until you
arrive at something false.
But many theorems that you want
to prove can be done directly.
All right, but not this one.
Now, we show the supremum
of the set does not exist.
So by contradiction, so we will
assume that such a supremum
does exist.
So suppose the supremum
exists and call it x.
All right, so x is the
supremum arm of the set.
OK, so by the previous
theorem, since x
is an element of the
rational numbers,
whose square gives me--
which is the
supremum of the set,
then x is bigger than or equal
to 1 and its square is 2.
By the previous theorem, x
is bigger than or equal to 1
and x squared equals 2.
In fact, x has to
be bigger than 1.
It cannot equal 1 because the
square would give me 1 not 2.
All right, so I can
make that statement
that x is, in fact,
bigger than 1,
not just bigger
than or equal to.
OK, so thus, since
x is a rational,
there exists m in
natural numbers
such that m is bigger than n
and x is equal to m over n.
So that just--
that's what it means
for x to be a rational number
and for it to be bigger than 1.
Thus, there exists an
n such that n times
x is a natural number.
All right, just
multiplying through by n,
that means that n
times x is equal to m,
which is a natural number.
So let S be the set
of natural numbers
so that when I multiply x
by k I get a natural number.
And so what we've shown,
just based on our assumption,
is that S is non-empty
because n is in S
Now, this is a subset
of natural numbers.
So by the well-ordering
property of N,
this set S has a least element,
which we'll call k0 in S.
So what I'm going to show is
that, in fact, this little guy
k0 is not, in fact, the
least element of this set S,
which would contradict
exactly how it's defined.
So define k1 to
be k0 x minus k0.
And note this is an integer.
Why?
Because k0 times x-- so k0 is
in the set S, meaning k0 times
x is a natural number.
So it's an integer.
k0 is a natural number.
So the difference of two
integers is, again, an integer.
So k0 is a natural number.
k0 times x is a natural number.
So the difference of two natural
numbers gives me an integer.
But in fact, it's
a natural number.
So it's a natural number.
So let's go over here.
So far, we have that
k1 is a natural number.
And I'm going to prove that
k1 is actually less than k0.
So since x squared equals 2--
I should say--
OK, so let's write it this way.
Since x squared is
equal to 2, this
implies that 4 minus
x squared is positive.
I mean, I just wrote down 2.
4 minus x squared is just 2.
So this tells me, taking
the difference, 2 minus x
times 2 plus x is positive.
2 and x are positive.
So I can divide this
inequality through by this term
and maintain the
inequality, which
implies 2 minus x is positive.
And therefore, x is less than 2.
So x is less than 2.
Then k1, which remember
is k0 times x minus 1,
is less than k0.
So k0 is a natural number.
It's positive. x minus 1 is
bounded by 2 minus 1 equals k0.
So what we've shown so far
is that this number, k1,
is a natural number.
And it's less than k0.
So I guess I don't have to
write this positive part.
Now, let's remember what
k0 was supposed to be.
k0 is supposed to be the
smallest element of this set
S. It's the smallest
natural number so
that when I multiply it by x
I get another natural number.
And from this k0, I constructed
a new natural number
called k1, which is less than
k0 and it's a natural number.
But here comes the fun part.
If we compute what
x times k1 is,
this is, by definition, x
times x times k0 minus k0.
This is equal to x squared
k0 minus x times k0, which
equals 2 k0 minus x times k0
because x squared equals 2.
And this last part, this
is equal to k0 plus k0
minus x k0, which equals k1.
Now, that's a natural number.
That's a natural number.
This natural number is bigger
than this natural number.
Therefore, their difference
is, again, a natural number.
So this says that x times
k1 is a natural number.
Thus, k1 is in S and
k1 is less than k0,
which implies k0 is not the
least element in S, which
is a contradiction
to the fact that it
is the least element of S.
So what we've shown is
assuming that this set
E has a supremum in
the rational numbers,
then we arrive at
a contradiction.
So our original
assumption must be false.
Thus, sup E does not exist.
All right, so this proof is
maybe a little different than--
if you've seen a proof of the
fact that the square root of 2
is not a rational
number, there's
a different proof that maybe
is a little bit simpler.
But this one uses ordering
instead to prove it,
which I thought was pretty cool.
And it's originally
due to Dedekind.
OK, so we've discussed one
aspect of the real numbers that
was in that theorem
that I stated earlier,
which I'll restate
in a minute, namely
that it is a set that has the
least upper bound property.
So I stated that as a theorem.
I'm not going to
prove that theorem.
We just want to
understand exactly what
sets the real numbers apart.
And one aspect of that--
there were two things.
One is that it's
an ordered field.
And two is that it has the
least upper bound property.
So we've now discussed what
the least upper bound property
means.
So we just need to
fill in one other part
about the real numbers,
which is the fact that it's
an ordered field.
And as I've said before, Q
is also an ordered field.
R is not special
in that respect.
But as the theorem stated at
the middle of the last lecture,
that R is, in fact, the
unique ordered field
with the least upper
bound property.
Remember, we've just proven that
Q does not have the least upper
bound property.
So in some sense,
Q is missing stuff.
It's missing stuff.
It's missing square
roots of 2, which
is kind of an
algebraic thing, namely
I can't solve the
equation x squared minus 2
equals 0 in the
rational numbers.
And the fact that
it's missing, that you
have this kind of
algebraic defect
manifests itself in this fact
that Q is also missing things
with respect to an order.
So Q, in short,
this is me saying
that has holes and R does not.
I mean, that is probably
the most basic statement
one can make about
R. And perhaps you
heard in high school
calculus and you're
hearing repeated now, but in a
nutshell, I mean, Q has holes
and R does not.
But this means something
very specifically
that R has the least upper
bound property and Q does not.
All right, so let me talk
about what ordered fields are.
So first off, I need to
define what a field is.
So a set F is a field if
it has two operations--
plus-- and I'm going to put
a dot here in the middle--
times basically,
such that you have
a list of properties
that hold with respect
to these operations.
The first is with respect to--
so this is plus, this is times.
This is addition,
multiplication.
So the first condition is that
the set is closed with respect
to taking sums.
So if x y is in F,
then x plus y is in F.
This operation of additions
should be commutative.
Commutativity, I hope
that's how you spell it.
This means that for all x y in
F, x plus y equals y plus x.
Associativity, so this is a
condition that for all x, y,
z in F, if I add x
and y and then add ,
this is equal to adding
x to the sum of y and z.
The fourth is that
we have what's
called an identity element,
an additive identity element.
There exists an element which
I'll label 0 in the set F
such that for all x in
F, 0 plus x equals 0.
And we also have additive
inverses, namely for all x in F
there exists an
element which I call--
which I label minus x in F such
that x plus minus x equals 0.
So these are the
conditions on addition
that should be
satisfied for a field.
So that's about addition.
So the conditions for
multiplication are similar.
Namely, it needs to be closed
with respect to multiplication.
So if x y is in F,
then x times y is in F.
Multiplication should
also be commutative.
So I'm just going to abbreviate
that commutative as comm.
For all x y in F, x
times y equals y times
x We also have associativity.
Let's not shorten it by that.
For all x, y, z in F,
if I multiply x times y
and then multiply it by
z, it's the same as taking
x and multiplying
it by y times z.
The fourth property
is the existence
of multiplicative identity.
There exists an element which
I label as 1 in the set F
such that for all x in
F, 1 times x equals x.
And then I also have
multiplicative inverses
for non-zero elements.
For all x in F, take away 0--
so for everything in the field
that's non-zero--
there exists an element which I
call x to the minus 1 in F such
that x times x to
the minus 1 equals 1.
Now, these are statements
about the two operations.
There's one last assumption
in the definition
that connects the two.
And that's the
distributive law, namely
that for all x, y, z in F,
if I take x plus y times z,
this is x times
z plus y times z.
So all these conditions--
so a field is a set with two
operations, plus and dot,
meaning multiplication.
And these two operations need to
satisfy all of these conditions
for my set to be called a field.
So the clearest
example is, of course,
rational numbers with
the usual plus and minus,
I mean plus and
multiplication defined
as you learned as a child.
Now, what's a non-example?
The integers.
So the integers come with
plus and multiplication.
However, it doesn't satisfy
the existence of inverses,
of multiplicative
inverses in 5, but it
does satisfy everything else.
And typically, one
would call z what's
called a commutative
ring, commutative
because multiplication
is also commutative.
But a ring in general
does not necessarily
have to satisfy multiplication.
Being commutative, for example,
the set of say 2 by 2 matrices
form a ring.
What's an example of another?
What's another
example of a field?
Well, we have-- maybe I should
have given this one first--
Z2, which is the
simplest field there is.
It's just the element
of two-- it's just
a set of two elements,
0 and 1, where
I need to define what 1 plus 1
is, 1 plus 1 defined to be 0.
And 1 plus 1 is 0.
And yeah, that's it.
I mean, 0 times 0 would be 0.
0 times 1 would be 0.
0 plus 0 would be 0.
And that gives you
all of the rules
you need to know to be able
to define multiplication
and addition on this set
of these two elements.
This is a field because
what is the inverse of 1?
Well, it's just 1.
And you can check that
if I define addition
by this rule along with
the other rules that--
and along with-- that
these defining plus
and multiplication this way
satisfies all the conditions
of being a field.
A more non-trivial example
would be, let's say, Z3.
This is a set 0, 1, 2.
Only now, the arithmetic-- so
I didn't use such a fancy word
here.
But arithmetic is
done mod 3 here.
Here, it was mod 2, meaning
if I want to add two elements,
I add them, and then I take
the remainder of that sum
after dividing by 3.
So here, addition
is defined mod 3.
So if something is a multiple
of 3, then I equate it to 0.
So for example, 1 plus
2, which gives me 3,
it's a multiple of 3.
This is defined to be 0.
2 times 2, which equals 4, which
equals 3 plus 1, multiples of 3
are 0.
So that gives me 1.
In particular, this tells
me that in this field,
2 times 2 equals 1.
So the multiplicative inverse
of 2 is given by itself, 2,
all right?
And a times b equals, let's
say, d mod 3, all right?
OK, so that's another
example of a field.
In fact, if you take mod
p where p is a prime,
you get another field.
You get a finite field.
So these are examples of
what are called finite fields
because exactly
that-- they are fields
and they have a finite
number of elements.
Now, OK, based on
just these assumptions
that you assume your
field to satisfy--
I mean, for it to
be a field, you
can prove all of the
simple algebra statements
that you've ever known simply
from these axioms of fields.
So for example, let
me just give you
the silliest example of a
statement you can prove just
using these elements--
I mean, these axioms.
You can prove the statement
that for all x in F--
so F is a field here.
So F throughout will be--
if x is a field, then for
all x in F, 0 times x is 0.
All we know about 0 is
that, when you add it to x,
you get x back.
Actually, this
should have been--
yeah, yeah, this is wrong.
This should have been x.
Let me make sure
there's no other errors.
I don't think there are.
That's another danger
about not being
able to lecture in person,
is that errors on the board
persist.
OK, so you can prove this
blockbuster theorem just using
these axioms.
So let's do a quick
proof of this.
If x is in F, then 0
is equal to 0 times
x plus the additive
inverse of 0 times
x because that's
just the definition
of the additive inverse.
Every element has
an additive inverse.
And now, 0 is equal to
0 plus 0 times x plus,
again, the additive
inverse of x.
And now, I use the
distributive law.
This is 0 times x plus 0 times
x plus the additive inverse of 0
times x.
And that cancels with that.
And I get 0 times x.
So I started off
with 0 and I arrived
at it's equal to 0
times x, all right?
And you can prove other
simple algebraic statements
using these axioms as well.
I think I'll put it
in the assignment.
And I'll just state you can
also prove things like--
if I want to look
at minus x, then
this is equal to the additive
inverse of 1 times x.
I mean, this is like--
it's not terribly
interesting at the start.
There are essentially some
very deep theorems in algebra
that you learn at another
point in your life,
but that won't be in this class.
Actually, today is
probably all we're
going to talk about fields,
which are algebraic things.
Algebraic things
are, to me, nice
because somehow you
always deal with equality.
So how hard could
it be to prove two
things are equal to each other?
Yet, analysis deals a lot
with inequality, which
somehow is much more subtle.
But that's just a little biased.
OK, so this is what a field is.
A field is just, again, a set
that has these two operations.
What is an ordered field?
So it's a field, first off, and
which is also an ordered set--
but it can't just--
you can't have two
different structures
on your field and them
not interact for that
to be interesting--
so such that the algebraic
structure and the order
on the field are
cohabitating nicely,
meaning you have two conditions
for all x, y, z in F.
If x is less than y, then x
plus z is less than y plus z.
And one other condition--
x is positive.
Or if x is bigger than 0
and y is bigger than 0,
then x times y is bigger than 0.
And I just use that
terminology anyways right now.
But for an ordered field F, if
an element is bigger than 0,
then we call it positive.
Or if it's bigger
than or equal to 0,
we say x is positive and
respectively non-negative.
So non-negative if x is
bigger than or equal to 0,
positive x is bigger than 0,
and then likewise with negative
and non-positive.
And so the most
basic example, again,
is Q. Q is an ordered
field with the usual order
and with the usual
algebraic structure on Q.
What is not an example is
either one of the two fields
I wrote down just a minute ago.
So a non-example is
this field here, 0, 1.
So if I put an order on
this, either 0 is less than 1
or 1 is less than 0.
So remember, order does not
have to necessarily correspond
to the fact that 0 you
connect to 0 in the integers
and that 1 you connect
to 1 in the integers.
I mean, these are just
two elements of a set.
And an order would
be saying either
that element is less
than that element
or that element is
less than that element.
So let's consider
either cases and suppose
we have that order on this set
and show that it does not turn
this set into an ordered field.
So then either 0 is less
than 1 or 1 is less than 0.
So let's do the first
case, 0 is less than 1.
If 0 is less than
1, then what happens
if I add 1 to each side?
So 1 plus 0 would give me 1.
1 plus one would be 0.
And therefore, it is not
so less than 1 plus 1.
So it does not satisfy
the first property.
So if I have an order on Z2,
two possibilities-- either 0
is less than 1 or
1 is less than 0.
If 0 is less than 1, then,
by the definition of addition
on this set, if I
add 1 to 0, I get 1.
If I add 1 to 1, I get 0.
And therefore, if I were
to add 1 to both sides,
I would not get
a true inequality
because I'm assuming
0 is less than 1.
So this condition, number 1,
does not hold for this order.
And neither does it hold for
choosing 1 is less than 0.
By the same logic, then 1--
so 1 plus 1 is not less than--
so this set is not--
this field cannot be turned
into an ordered field.
And essentially, the same thing
that I've done here shows that
you cannot have any
finite ordered field.
So in general, there are
no finite ordered fields.
Now, just like we proved
the blockbuster statement
that 0 times anything
in the field equals 0,
we can also prove all of the
manipulations of inequalities
that you use without
fear simply from, again,
these axioms about an
ordered field being a field
and also satisfying
these two inequalities--
I mean, these two
conditions here for it
to be an ordered field.
So for example, if F
is an ordered field,
then if x is an element
of f and x is positive,
this implies its additive
inverse is negative and vice
versa.
If x is less than 0,
then minus x is positive.
So I know it's tempting
to think, well yeah, just
multiply this inequality by
minus 1 to get this inequality.
But remember, this
is really a statement
about the additive inverse of x.
So the proof is not hard.
If x is positive, then--
well, I could write it this way.
I can write it as
0 is less than x.
Then by property number 1, I
can add anything to both sides
and get the same inequality--
and preserve the inequality.
Therefore, minus x plus 0 is
less than the additive inverse
of x plus x.
Now, by the fact that 0 is
the additive identity, a4,
the left side, is
going to be minus x.
And by the definition of
the additive inverse of x,
The right-hand side
is going to be 0.
And that's it.
So what's going in here
is this is by a4 and a5.
And this previous statement is
by 1 in this definition before.
And I'm not going to prove
this statement as well.
It's the essentially
the same proof.
I add minus x to both
sides, which I can do by 1.
And then I use a4 and a5
to conclude that x is--
that minus x is positive.
Let me just say See
Proposition 1.1.8 in textbook
for the other--
let's say for the other
proofs of standard inequality
manipulations.
So Q is an ordered field.
And as I stated before
about R, R will also--
R is also an ordered field.
But it has a least
upper bound property.
So maybe you are
asking yourself, how
about some sort of greatest
lower bound property?
The least upper bound
property is about sups.
Can we make a similar
property about infs?
Are there sets that have the
least upper bound property
that don't have, say, a greatest
lower bound property, meaning
does there exist something
has the greatest lower bound
property if every non-empty
set which is bounded below
has an infimum?
That's kind of what I'm
referring to, even though I
haven't written it down.
OK, what is that leading up to?
In the setting of
ordered fields,
there really is no difference
between a least upper
bound property and a greatest
lower bound property.
If I have an ordered field
which satisfies the least upper
bound property, then
it also satisfies
a greatest lower bound property,
which I'll state as a theorem,
and then we'll prove.
Let F be an ordered field with
the least upper bound property.
Now, I'm going to prove
that it has, if you like,
a greatest lower bound property.
Then if A is a
subset of F, which
is non-empty and bounded
below, then inf A exists in F,
meaning A has an
infimum in the set F.
OK, so the proof of
this is basically--
in some sense, we
did something similar
when we proved that one set
given by all the minus 1,
minus 2, minus 3 had
the greatest upper bound
property or the least
upper bound property
by taking its minus
and then using,
in a sense, the greatest
lower bound property
of the natural numbers, this
well-ordering principle,
to conclude that that set had
the least upper bound property.
And that's what we're
going to do here,
is we're going to take a
set which is bounded below,
take its minus, if you like,
which is now bounded above,
take the sup of that
set, which we can do,
and show that that's
the infimum of that set.
So let me write over here.
This should be not part of
the proof, but some intuition.
And I'll draw it like F is
a real number line, which
it is because part
of the statement
about the real
numbers is that it's
the unique ordered field with
the least upper bound property.
But don't worry
about that for now.
Let's imagine we have a
set A. And for now, I'll
draw it like it's an interval,
which is bounded below.
So it stops after some point.
And there's nothing there.
So it's bounded below,
then if I look at minus A--
so here, I'm drawing 0.
If I look at minus A, which
is the set of elements--
the set of the
additive inverses of A,
I now have a set which
is bounded above.
So if this is a
lower bound for A,
then minus B will be an
upper bound for minus A.
And therefore, minus A has
a least upper bound which,
in this picture I'm
drawing, looks like x.
And so then my goal
is then to show that--
so here, let's go
back to B. Here's A.
And here's now minus
x to show that minus x
is an infinum of A. So that's
the basic intuition on why
this holds.
We're using the
ordered field property
to be able to take minuses.
That's where the field
property is coming in.
And that minuses-- although
we didn't prove this,
it is one of those--
essentially, we did prove
this, that if I have something
positive and I multiply it
through by minus 1 using this
as well, then that
reverses the inequality.
But again, these are short--
unless I'm telling you to
prove a certain inequality,
simple inequality statement
like of this type, just
freely use the
inequality facts that you
remember from high school.
And just know that these
persist for ordered fields
with the least--
or ordered fields in general.
OK, so let's turn this
intuition into a proof.
Suppose A-- so I am
not stating it here,
but F is an ordered field with
the least upper bound property.
I'll go ahead and state it.
F is an ordered field with the
least upper bound property.
Let A be subset
of F, A not equal
to an empty set,
A bounded below.
Then that means there exists
an element b in F such
that b is less than
or equal to a such
that, for all a in capital A,
b is less than or equal to a.
So I mean, the proof
is essentially there
and you just need to
turn it into English
because we're in Massachusetts.
If you were in a
different country,
you'd turn into the language
that's spoken there.
You just need to turn
it into written word.
So there exists a
lower bound for A.
Let me just note another
set called minus--
which I'll label minus A. This
is the set of all elements
in F of the form minus the
additive inverses of A,
as a is in capital A. So
it's the additive inverse
of all elements
in capital A. Then
the fact that I have
for all a in A b
is less than or equal to a
implies for all a in A, minus a
is less than or equal to minus
b because multiplying through
by minus 1 flips the inequality.
That implies-- so
minus b is bigger than
or equal to every
element of minus A So
that implies b is an upper
bound for the set minus A.
So minus A is a non-empty subset
of F, which is bounded above.
Therefore, it has a supremum.
Thus, there exists
an x in F such
that x equals sup
of the set minus A.
And this is because we are
assuming the least upper
bound property, that every
non-empty set which is bounded
above has a supremum.
I'm going to show this guy x is,
in fact, the infimum of the set
A, or minus x is
the infimum of A.
So the fact that x is
the supremum of minus A
implies that for all a in
capital A, minus a is less than
or equal to x
because x is supposed
to be the least upper bound.
So it's, in fact,
an upper bound.
So that means that
for all a in A--
again, just flipping the
inequalities-- minus x is less
than or equal to A,
which implies minus x
is a lower bound for capital A.
We now have to show that minus
x is the greatest lower bound
of A. If I take any
other lower bound of A,
then minus x is bigger than
or equal to that lower bound.
Now show that if--
let's call it something else--
y is the lower bound for
A, then y is less than
or equal to minus x.
And then that
concludes the proof
showing that minus x is,
in fact, the infimum of A.
And therefore, A has an infinum.
We've actually identified
what the infinum is.
It's the sup of minus A.
OK, so let y be a
lower bound for A.
Then exactly how I showed
for this single lower bound
that I had for A, you
can verify this again.
Just go through the argument
and replace b with y.
Then minus y is an upper bound--
just look at the picture,
replace b with y--
for minus A, which implies
since x is the supremum of A--
so since x is the
supremum of minus A,
it's the least upper bound.
So it has to be less
than or equal to minus y.
And flipping the
inequality again on that
means that y is
less than or equal
to minus x which is
what we wanted to prove.
Thus, the inf of A exists.
And we've, in fact,
showed that it's
equal to the sup of minus
A. So in an ordered field
with the least upper
bound property,
not only does every set which is
bounded above have a supremum,
every set which is bounded
below has an infimum.
So now, we move on and not
talk about generalities,
but we're just going to focus
on R, the set of real numbers.
And I'm just going
to, again, state
this theorem about
the existence of R
and its properties,
so just to bring this
all back to our goal of
describing exactly what R is
or what separates it
from Q is that-- so there
exists a unique ordered
field with the least
upper bound property
containing Q.
And this field we denote by R.
So Q does-- just
to bring this back,
so we started off in ancient
times with the natural numbers.
We moved to the
integers so that we
could take additive
inverses, although they
didn't call them that.
And we wanted 0.
And then we moved to
the rational numbers
because we didn't have
ways to solve the equation
2x plus 1 equals 0.
And so we moved on
from Q to R essentially
because we can't solve the
equation x squared minus 2
equals 0.
And this inability to
solve x squared minus 2
equals 0, although an
algebraic fact, in fact
means that Q is incomplete
as an ordered set.
It does not have this
least upper bound property.
And what characterizes
the real numbers
is that it is an ordered
field containing Q.
And it's the unique one with
the least upper bound property.
This unique should
be kind of in quotes
because unique up to
what's called isomorphism.
Isomorphism is a fancy way of
saying what you call apples
I call manzanas, essentially.
OK, so this is what R is.
It's the unique ordered
field with the least
upper bound property
containing Q.
So I'm not going to
prove this theorem.
The way you usually
prove this theorem,
you construct R either as
what are called Dedekind cuts
or as equivalence classes
of Cauchy sequences.
We'll talk about Cauchy
sequences soon-ish.
But I'm more interested in
proving properties about R,
and then going on to
functions on R, limits,
which is what analysis is,
is the study of limits,
rather than get tied up in
really non-analytic facts,
algebraic facts
trying to construct
this R, the actual field.
So we're just going to
take this as a given.
And now, we're going
to go from here
and start proving facts
about real numbers.
Where Q failed, R succeeds.
So the first fact is that
there exists a unique element
in R such that r is positive
and r squared equals 2.
So we saw before that
if I replace this
with Q, ta rational
number, that's false.
There does not exist a rational
number whose square is 2.
But in the real
numbers, there does.
And right now, maybe you're
tempted to just say, yeah,
you set R equal to
square root of 2.
Well, what is square root of 2?
I mean, how do you
come up with that guy?
So we have to come up with some
element of R whose square is 2.
Now, we basically
did that a minute
ago in the rational numbers.
And kind of the same
proof works here.
So let E be the set of all x's
in R such that x is positive
and x squared is less than 2.
So earlier in the lecture and
at the end of the last lecture,
we had q here, right?
Well, the same proof, basically
And what we did earlier-- then
E is bounded above by 2.
So R, which I--
so sup E tilde exists in R.
So I have this set.
It's bounded above by 2.
I mean, we did
the proof earlier.
So by the least upper
bound property of R,
the supremum exists.
Call this element little r.
Then the same proof--
I'm not going to do it again
because we've already done it.
And all you need to do
is replace q's with r's--
shows r is bigger
than or equal to 1.
In fact, it's bigger than 1.
And r squared equals 2.
So there does exist an
element of r which is positive
and whose square is 2.
Now, I will prove
that it's unique.
So now, I want to
prove that r is unique.
That means if I
take-- if there's
some other element in capital
R that satisfies these two
inequalities, then it must
be equal to my original r.
So suppose r tilde is in R.
r tilde is bigger than 0.
And r tilde squared equals 2.
Then since their square
is the same number,
namely 2, 0 is equal to
r tilde minus r squared,
which equals r tilde
plus r, r tilde minus r.
Now, both r and r
tilde are positive.
So r plus r tilde is positive.
In particular, it's non-zero.
So since it's a field, I can
therefore divide or multiply
both sides by the additive
inverse of this thing
and arrive at 0 is equal
to r tilde minus r or r
equals r tilde.
So there exist only one
element in the real numbers
which is positive and
whose square is 2.
And I'll put it on the
assignment, namely that--
so this shows what?
Square root of 2 exists.
But you can then show a
cube root of 2 exists in R.
And we'll not prove this.
But you can show, in general,
that if x is in R, then x
to the 1 over n--
that should say x-- is positive
for all natural numbers.
So where Q failed, R succeeds.
And it's doing
this-- or the fact
that it does succeed
is not coming
from an algebraic
property of R. It's
coming from this
property about its order.
All right, we'll stop there.